thank you for joining us for the fifth
annual clinical diagnostics and research
online conference life technologies a
brand of thermo Fisher is a proud
sponsor of this conference where we will
focus on presentations themed around
unraveling the complexity of oncology
research my name is Carol kashayam
senior marketing manager of clinical
research and will be your moderator for
today's presentation I'm proud to
introduce dr. Jeffrey whitesell who will
be our first speaker in this week series
dr. whitesell is the director of
clinical cancer genomics and director of
cancer screening screening and
prevention at the City of Hope
Comprehensive Cancer Center he's also a
clinical professor of preventive
medicine at the University of Southern
California School of Medicine today dr.
weitzel will speak on establishing an
economic baraka 1 and 2 gene analysis
research workflow using custom amplitude
panel design and I on PGM system at the
end of the presentation I will be
facilitating QA so feel free to submit
questions on the screen during the
presentation I will now like to turn it
over to dr. whitesell for his
presentation all right well good morning
thank you for joining us today I so we
have a number of attendees first a
couple of points I'm a medical
oncologist and a geneticist so I come to
this from perspective of being a
clinician who does cancer genetics care
and also cancer genetics research in my
laboratory so I really come with a
clinicians perspective though and that's
looking for things that are useful to me
or useful to other people and so you'll
see when I do my presentation today that
rather than it being although there are
going to be technical details and I'm
not a technical virtuoso I'm much more
interested in how we use these tools to
get to clinical
care and the research along the way
that's necessary to give us tools so
that's my perspective second is I tend
to pronounce the gene names brca1 and
brca2 I spell them out so to speak the
term Branca really comes from the
marketing of the one vendor who had
single ability to market this test for
the last more than the last decade so
there's some in the field who are
sensitized to the way the genes are
labeled but nonetheless we use the
formal gene names in any event and I've
come representing not just me and the
City of Hope but an entire clinical
kinetics community of practice we've got
a training program for people who are
trying to become clinicians and do work
as clinicians and cancer genetics and
through this course we have an entire
community of practice in many states in
the US as well as globally and so I
represent them here today as well all
right so first we'll start with since
we're talking about the BRCA genes um
this is a slide from New England Journal
of Medicine in 2010 but highlighted
rather interesting set of events and it
really relates to intellectual property
and jeans the essential thing being can
you patented gene can you patent nature
as a better way to say it I've
highlighted at the beginning here that
you've got for example in 1953 the
original publication by Watson and Crick
I'd like to highlight that because in
2003 is rather fun to be talking about
the 50th anniversary of their paper and
if you've ever read that paper you
really haven't you should it talks about
things in much more flowing grows than
are usually very sterile got discourse
that we have in any of our given
journals today and they postulate about
how this code must help to convey the
information in a reliable way and of
course we have a world of information
since then I'm then fast-forwarding to
the next highlighted box in my mind one
of the critical issues was that there
was an international breast cancer
linkage consortium the bcl see that was
founded in around 1989 and this was
basically a set of about 200
very high risk families that looked like
hereditary breast and ovarian cancer and
they were it was in this setting that
they used as a common set of patients to
try and do the linkage so as we go
forward in 1990 the critical event was
Jeff Hall in Marie Claire Kings lab I
had done linkage analysis and showed
that brca1 first off that it existed
they gave it the name brca1 breast
cancer gene one at the time marico King
has commented on the fact that you know
she was at Berkeley California then and
she jokes that brca1 stands for Berkeley
California one but but the fact is is
that this was breast cancer gene one
that's how that was named and the
linkage established that it existed up
till that point nobody believed that any
single gene would it come for a large
proportion of cases and second gave us
the address on chromosome 17 then there
was about a four year horse race of
sorts and then an academic industrial
alliance resulted in the cloning and
sequencing of brca1 in 1994 and that was
reported at the montreal american side
of human genetics meeting that was my
first human genetics meeting and was
really quite an exciting time I thought
all the meetings would be that exciting
but of course they aren't always that
exciting I'm one year later because what
was clear was that among the families
those high risk families that appeared
to have hereditary breast cancer only a
proportion maybe two-thirds were
explained by brca1 and so the search
continued and within the year brca2
cloning and sequencing was reported
brca1 of courses on chromosome 17 brca2
is on chromosome 13 commercial testing
in the United States first became
available in 1996 and then this
highlights the fact that patents were
awarded by the US for BRCA wanted to so
at least in my world we've had no choice
but to use one given vendor that had
intellectual property rights in this
regard now going forward I highlighted
here on this chart that in 2006 finally
will be the word i'll use large
rearrangement screening was added
to the test and I think that's important
as geneticists I don't know if anybody
who's a 10 who's attending this webinar
who wouldn't normally want to be as
thorough as they can for a testing
strategy and there's a clear recognition
that for brca1 and brca2 up to ten
percent of mutations can be large
rearrangements which are not detectable
by sequencing in general at least
certainly not Sanger sequencing and that
the number of large rearrangements
however is really focused on brca1 the
brca1 gene is forty-one percent a low
sequences so it has a propensity to
these larger arrangements shuffling of
the exons either deletion or duplication
and so it's about a five to one ratio of
brca1 rearranged was compared to BRC to
so many clinical approaches often
involve screening for large
rearrangements at the least in brca1
sometimes ignoring brca2 though among
our consortium that I'm going to tell
you about there is a brca2 founder
rearrangement I believe that is has to
be detected by my colleagues in Europe
um then the next step in this timeline
really is quite interesting and that was
this past june june 2013 the US Supreme
Court ruled that as nature genes can't
be patented that's really opened up
quite an avenue for the opportunity to
take different approaches to genetic
testing so I'm going to highlight where
we go from here and the other thing
happened of course almost at the same
time I think a month or so before the
Supreme Court decision was Angelina
Jolie's announcement that she was a
brca1 carrier this really did put things
back in the spotlight even though I
thought that clinical cancer genetics
was getting a bit state we've been doing
genetic testing for BRCA at least in the
US and Western Europe for more than a
decade then over that decade acquired
information about what we do with
individuals but angeline have really
reminded us that that no matter how much
we think we've been teaching about a
given element of what is important in
health science um that such publicity
can really magnify and
again there went into the spotlight for
those of you who don't know again this
is publicly available information
Angelina Jolie's mother died of ovarian
cancer at age 48 and ovarian cancer is
one of the sinequan ins of retro breast
ovarian cancer syndrome now this is the
actual sequence of brca1 and brca2 and I
want to credit for this slide that of
course you can't read it I want to
credit for this slide I'm Tom Frank who
was the first laboratory director for
myriad genetics and he was a wonderful
man in his past he's a wonderful guy and
he had shared this of course you can't
see it but in this case there was an
insertion of an a that shouldn't have
been there and so going through this
used to be quite difficult and expensive
expensive meaning in the US it started
at around two thousand dollars for
complete sequencing of the seventeen
thousand base pairs of coding and
adjacent intronic regions and it most
recently was as much as 4,000 US dollars
to completely analyze brca1 and brca2
and now things of course have moved on
and we'll talk ever so briefly at the
end about multigene panel approaches but
this was the state-of-the-art for the
longest time and this is the actual
coding sequence and I'm using the past
tense here was difficult and expensive
because of course we're going to be
talking about next-generation
technologies here so among the
next-generation technologies and I would
refer the listener to the available
review this journal of journal Clinical
Oncology in 2013 and a series of
articles the references at the bottom
here that has series of articles that
were really quite helpful as a summary
of the clinical applications of genetics
and genomics so I would refer the reader
there for further information but really
highlighted the fact that you know
you've got Sanger sequencing which has
been the gold standard fairly expensive
on a per base pair perspective but
really high accuracy and considered more
or less the gold standard and when you
look at the traces you know typically
we're suppressing anything that's below
a certain level and therefore trying to
maintain high read fidelity one of the
it's interesting that we we don't have
time to talk about today but is relevant
to next generation approaches is that
with this massively resampling again the
massively parallel sequencing which is
in the next two boxes in the next box in
particular we can start to see mosaicism
in some cases that is small
subpopulations that's of course one of
the advantages when applying these tools
to somatic genetics that is the genetics
of a given tumor looking for druggable
targets and we're often looking at
minority populations so you don't
necessarily suppress the reading of the
minority populations when using the
massively parallel sequencing but of
course this massively parallel approach
comes with economies of scale so read
accuracy goes down but the cost per base
pair goes way down and that's really
been ended I think some emerging
technologies of our interesting
single-molecule applica molecule
analyses again slightly lower read
accuracy but extremely low cost so I
think this is a very exciting time to be
involved in genetic and genomic research
because of the potential for these
differences and the cost differential is
depicted here for those of you who
aren't familiar with Moore's law more
and was involved the semiconductor
science so I believe he is one of the
founding members of Intel and his theory
and hit what really was born out was
that basically something like every 18
months they can double the number of
transistors on a silicon chip and that
increases the power decreases the cost
and so that's why our phones today have
more computer power than the rocket that
went to the moon a number of years ago
so reality is is that they're
semiconductors were getting cheaper
every year by the megabyte and for quite
a time genetic technologies and genetic
sequencing costs followed the same line
until recently it just completely
dropped off so around two thousand eight
when the next gen sequences were first
introduced you really see this huge drop
off of the cost and I think the reality
is here that
at least in terms of raw sequence read
it is it is possible now to do the
entire genome for about a thousand
dollars now not necessarily a good
fidelity depth of reading and doesn't
include the farm from attic analysis but
about a thousand dollars to acquire the
data at a rough first pass and I think
that that's pretty remarkable given that
up to the time the first genome was
reported around 2001 it took ten years
and more than three billion dollars to
sequence one person's genome and now
we're talking about doing the entire
process genome and perhaps a couple of
weeks for perhaps a thousand dollars on
the underneath is the different
technology platforms that have been
advanced pyrosequencing was quite
exciting when it first came out in 2005
but I think has really been supplanted
now when you go further with many of the
alumina machines and of course we're
talking about Ion Torrent and the life
sciences products here today as well but
the ayah torrent PGM as well as the
other the proton and other systems so
these are really the more current
systems in use and I'll talk a little
bit about our use of at least one of
those systems so again I'm clinician
remember so my focus is on breast
ovarian cancer it's actually on all
hereditary cancers but for this talks
purposes breast or ovarian cancer and
the other thing we've been doing I do a
lot of work in is a realm of disparities
and in disparities I mean who has access
to genetic testing so for the most part
it's only been Western European and
other individuals but the question is is
hereditary cancer different in different
populations at least five percent of
breast cancer and fifteen percent or
greater of ovarian cancers are
hereditary of course you end up having
to test 10 times the number of people
who have a mutation to find a mutation
if you're following guidelines that is
you'll test 10 people to find one BRCA
carrier and for the ovarian cancer maybe
test five people to find one you do see
these small proportions so it's really
the problem is breast cancers a comment
so figure out who to test is one thing
if the test is cheap enough you just
test everybody now to get to this
question of other sizes so again this is
sariah she was a she went to latin pot
grammy and i'm not presenting personally
identifiable health information the
pedigree that you see on this slide was
derived from her obituary her mother her
aunt and her grandmother all had breast
cancer so i think it's a crime that this
person developed breast cancer locally
advanced at 37 without any real warning
our opportunity for predisposition
testing and so does it occur do genetic
causes of cancer occur in latin america
for example one of my areas of interest
of focus yes it does so as I mentioned
access to care influences the knowledge
of genetic epidemiology almost all of
the world's literature on the genetic
epidemiology of breast cancer comes from
the United States Western Europe Iceland
in Israel because of unique founder
effects and Australia has a very well
developed cancer genetic system as well
now other parts of the world Columbia
we've been doing some work and others
have reported there the Bahamas have
some unique genetic features in terms of
founder effects and my dear friend and
colleague from the University color
University of Chicago doctor foo meola
party has done amazing work in Nigeria
and I know that dr. Tim rebeck when it
comes to prostate cancer and other
genetics has been heavily involved in
Africa so many of us are devoted to the
cause of bringing genetics to all world
populations with the idea of enhancing
access to this care now the North
American commercial vendor published in
2009 Michael Hall who's at Fox Chase
university had was the lead author of
this paper summarizing Myriad's data and
just goes to show you that if you look
at the this panel that Western Europeans
were the majority of cases items that
were sequenced followed by central
Europeans interestingly the Latin
American population here almost 2,000
cases when published in 2009 but I
can tell you that my program alone
because of our outreach to the local
Latino population at one of our County
safety net hospitals was responsible 500
to 800 of these cases alone so
substantial portion but still a pittance
if you look at this less than 2,000 here
compared to 20 times that many people
from Western Europe and so the
consequence has been very little
knowledge about many of these sub-set
groups of individuals so like looking
for our pointer but I there we are edit
nope on the Edit I'm just trying to find
my editing but one but that's ok so i
work at City of Hope I'm out in Los
Angeles and this represents a map my
collaborative network people who are
working with us to try and solve genetic
epidemiology issues these are people in
my community can search in clinical
kinetics community of practice who are
employing a common protocol for our
registry so this is just illustrate that
but one to highlight is that I have
collaborators in Guadalajara dr. Adrian
canary and as a cena del Toro and at in
can in Mexico City so Cynthia Villarreal
Luis Herrera Alejandro mohar Rosie
Alvarez there's a whole team of people
were working with and in Puerto Rico
with Marcia Cruz Korea Julie duty and
dr. doom I air whom Pierre and so folks
across the country and together by
looking at the epidemiology of BRCA in
Latinos we published almost a year ago
on 14 network sites 746 participants a
large number of mutations and we were
able to generate some hypotheses but I
want to point out that again this is
some of this was the largest population
of Latinos sequence for BRCA genes in
the literature to date in 2013 given the
representation of nearly 40 or 50,000
for Western Europeans you can see there
is still a disparity so
I join together this was a group that
was more or less self-assembled led in
large part by jose luis Costa and Jose
Carlos mikado of patnam in Portugal and
by dr. mezan cap and lichtenberg in the
Netherlands and also I've been pushing
folks at life sciences to help us move
this along as well so between us we've
convinced we were convinced that
developing a common platform for doing
BRCA testing on a next generation
platform that could easily be
disseminated was worthwhile and so
that's why coins is deploying a common
protocol so this may not look as global
as it could be obviously we're missing
asia africa and south america but many
for most of what we do will be
applicable to those other areas so i
want to highlight dr. Hidalgo who's at
the image and the genomics Institute in
Mexico City our Center in Los Angeles we
have centered Canada Scotland and of
course Portugal the Netherlands and also
of course in Germany what was the
consortium schools want to develop an
ample sake platform for doing next-gen
research with brca genes ultimately we'd
like to give the technology up to speed
and the informatics pipeline so that
this could be applied where possible for
benefit of the individuals but our
research encompasses the following first
we need a good coverage of the target if
you're going to try and do clinical
grade sequencing need a one hundred
percent coverage of all the coding exons
and introns exon boundaries plus 20-20
generally applicants covering the exons
need to be overlapping and we need to be
careful about that particular because of
the potential for snips single
nucleotide polymorphisms to disrupt any
given amplicon wanted it here given that
it was being developed initially by the
folks in Portugal and melons to the
european molecular jacks quality network
guidelines I'll comment on that again in
a moment and then we want it to be
adoptable by the research labs accurate
affordable
easy I'm easy as a word abused often and
I think that applies to any new
technology but I will say that the
ability to do a single day or a few day
workflow to do a certain number of chips
and actually this is a mistake here it
says at least samples six samples per
chip and you'll find out that we have up
to eight samples for the 316 chip
currently and again we wanted to be
reliable with easy data analysis for
this purpose you can have many different
workflows of course the iron reporter is
associated with the life sciences group
and so that could be a turnkey system
that would be ideal so the resulting
design was felt to meet requirements so
the folks in Portugal Netherlands got
together working with life sciences
designed the pool 167 amplicons 3 primer
pools requires 13 anagrams of DNA
starting dealing which is really a
miniscule quantity of course there were
200 base pair design because the PGM the
person genome machine the Ion Torrent
can get up to 200 base pairs fairly
reliably that differentiates it from
some of the other platforms where
perhaps the reed links are shorter 100
150 formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
sorry for the acronym ffpe can be done
but slightly lower performance because
of the poor quality of the DNA but it
certainly can be done I think the
protons probably more adept for that and
again no snips in the 3 prime end of the
primer so these are the European best
practice guidelines and which are
highlighted in the blue box here we
started with a three-phase project plan
and verification experiments first phase
was involvement of the design which was
just described for you next was to
analyze 20 archive samples and this was
again done between the Netherlands and a
patent up in Portugal nine more homo
polymer variants were particularly
focused on as well as a look-see to see
if we could see large rearrangements
that's what their MLP variants a room
referring to the flow is fairly
straightforward multiplex PCR with three
pools 55 primer pairs bar coding is of
course done to enable the multiplexing
template is prepared you can see the
time listed there again these are
idealized times I would have to say you
got the barcode adapter ligations you
run the sequence amplify and analyze the
data so this is the ideal a sequence
that you can see the idealized hours the
year so it is it is technically
conceivable to do it in a day's run
though I think in practical terms my
technician Joseph Herzog was very adept
at these things in fact incredibly adept
at these things might take it two days
to get it done but again with meticulous
care you get good results also learning
the protocol the first runs this is the
data from patnam and from the
netherlands showing the metrics were
good they had a hundred percent coverage
of the open reading frames there was
average coverage uniformity of ninety
eight point eight percent which is
pretty good average on target
specificity I am NOT a bomb from an
assist and so you'll have to judge the
individual characteristics your cells
and certainly would encourage you to
consult with the folks either at iron
tort or otherwise regarding what this
means in terms of the quality but this
is high quality fine so got through the
design now 30 archive samples with 65
different variants tested exchanged
across two labs and so they were able to
look at on variants and were able to of
course compare between their two labs
that they can each pick up the same
things deletions and insertions point
mutations and then they tested to see if
they can pick up exxon deletions they
multiplex eight samples on 13 16 chip
and from there it's hard to read this
but the pipeline really just says it
basically this is a standard pipeline
assembly of the alignment the coverage
analysis step and then del detection
annotation of the variance then the
ability to interact with the various
databases
to identify known pathogenic variants
things that are already in the DB snip
databases polymorphisms and the like and
to verify these variants and then to
extract the report so this is the ion
reporter depicted workflow others have
applied their own workflows that have
their own but I think this is a workflow
that we were all trying to use as a
consortium looking for a turnkey
operation so the report may look like
this when you get it done and again here
this is just hollin you can't see it
very well and I can't amplify it but
basically you have the identifier on
this is this will tell you which
individual this'll tell you the type of
change this is the predicted protein
coding change here it's a four base
correct change and then you've got it's
a gene as brca2 and then it can even get
over here to get some of the annotations
and does it have an entry in DB snip
uncle mine uncle mine type and so these
are the kind of annotations you can get
there's a real learning curve to this
but you can customize your own workflow
if your unique population has recurrent
mutations or recurrent variants you can
ultimately filter this in different ways
so I'm not going to go into the details
of that because it is really use it and
figure out how to do it sort of
territory but suffice it to say that you
can customize the workflow and at first
I will tell you as a non non environment
is this person it is daunting to me but
others can certainly manage it just fine
and is exciting to start calming the
data and seeing what you can get for
yourself reproducibly studies were done
so in this consortium that we created
among all the sites almost all the sites
so here's the city of hope that's what
coh stands for the other sites are
mentioned here so there are certain
variants the ones that are listed here
that were selected and tested across
multiple site platforms to be sure that
we could all detect the same things so
again multiple layers of overlap and non
overlap to be sure that we had sampled
thoroughly only a few spots didn't have
those mutations in their pool so this is
a summary we've had a hundred percent
coverage of the target regions
coverage was 100 x that was the goal was
at least 100 x coverage I think the
standards for sort of clinical grade
sequencing are still in evolution but
most people feel that at least 75 to 100
x coverage is essential you can see here
then I'll go it is hard to read the
numbers up or literally at a thousand X
coverage for most of the exons and these
are multiple different labs pulling of
their runs to show that pretty reliably
across multiple labs we can detect a
high level um one amplicon had as low as
60 X coverage and that was the exception
we've done some subsequent spiking
experiments we meaning the folks in the
Portugal and the Netherlands in terms of
their respective labs they really were
the ones who are doing the powerhouse
initial development of this and are
trying to rectify that but really
doesn't need to be rectified it doesn't
have a lot of homopolymers in that lead
area and we've over said we've saturated
that area with additional mutations to
detect to be sure that it was effective
nonetheless good coverage again you can
see that varians can be detecting this
exon with a comfort flow 350,000 map
treats on average per bar coded sample
so for a gene of 17,500 coding sequence
that's pretty good coverage mean depth
of coverage as I mentioned was over a
thousand so here as much as 2,000 per
amplicon thus we had done this and then
the next step was global verification so
we've got good performance
characteristics can we among our eight
labs find all the variants that we think
we should so we had archive samples that
had known complete Sanger sequence and
were well characterized so each of a
selected lists of work non-overlapping
so that there were some that were
overlapping because they're seeing
globally in different settings and
others that were unique to given
countries and therefore we achieved the
opportunity to have I believe it was 151
unique variance we also had to work with
the false positive detection rate
because we noticed for example that a
large deletion that was Adele 56
mutation was not pink
that was being suppressed in the
programmatic pathway well we then
adjusted the software this is chris
anthe who does most of this work for
life sciences and really worked hard at
creating the flow the workflow but you
can see here the true positive false
positive rate very good numbers here
although some of us might argue that if
you were trying to apply this in the
clinical setting you'd have to have
improvement on this because you have to
be able to be sure of what you have or
not have to do a lot of secondary
verification steps certainly for now one
would probably want to do saying or
sequencing of a given variant to confirm
it and there's a lot of other reasons to
flow in your clinical realm I won't
comment on that I don't run a clinical
laboratory I run a research laboratory
but others who are interested in this
pathway are interested in ways of
designing economical workflows for
commercial purposes nonetheless this is
using eight samples on a 316 chip this
is what our consortiums worked on
together I can tell you that using the
larger chip the 318 you can get even
greater economies of scale and we scaled
up the number of samples proportionate
to the capacity of that chip and again
just a complexity with the bar coding is
quite manageable so this is again a
summary of the predictive value so in
Longhorn polymer tracks there were 11
unique mutations we really made sure
that there is good representation of
mutations in those tracks which are
known to be challenging for calls 12 of
13 were picked up one no call the rest
and there were no missed calls there was
one no call so at least you'd know to
look there more carefully with a
calculated sensitivity based on 12 of 13
92 + % 4 in dells 120 120 picked up
again no mr. non calls and then four
point mutations excellent coverage 86 of
86 picked up so the overall across all
of these even the challenging stretch
events was ninety nine point five
percent sensitivity I don't think
there's any technique out there that has
a hundred percent sensitivity but I
think that would have to be considered
so the problem is is of course not all
of us have a bomb from an assist I love
the new
our articles are the New Yorker cartoons
it was so typically brilliant of you to
have invited a farm format assist this
actually used to say epidemiologist but
I changed it because I think that bomb
from attics is an art that we need even
more today to help make smooth workflows
so in summary aren't global consortium
really a band of brothers and the
sisters created I've been using this
technical platform it's been established
in all of our centers and I think has
excellent performance wrist Ock's a
hundred percent coverage of the targeted
reasons more than 100 x coverage across
all but one amplicon and some of that's
being dealt with mutations detected were
in home polymer stretches deletions and
insertions point mutations exon
deletions now reliable large
rearrangement identification is much
more challenging you actually need to
have primers at Kyle across introns to
really get good breakpoint
identification of amplifications and
duplications and deletions of exons we
are able to see by pooling a number of
samples in the one run and then using
them as internal controls against one
another we were able to see one of our
large range mutations that's common in
Latin America or in Mexico but not as
reliable as we'd like to so there are
still efforts in progress here to try
and create cnv detection methods to use
this same workflow to get there but I
think it's going to require some
additional modifications as mentioned
barcoding enables analysis of eight
samples Embleton some 316 chip and we
can do more on the 318 chip and again
this is a demonstration that as a group
with close collaboration among peers
this work demonstrates the potential for
mutational analysis of brca1 and 2 using
the eye on a fancy technology combined
with the PGM system one of the reasons I
chose that system didn't have to deal
with it being the cheapest system
because frankly on a base pair of my
bass player basis it's not the cheapest
system much larger platforms are cheaper
but you have to bar code in and and
multiplex multiple multiple samples to
get those economies of scale I was also
looking for a platform
that didn't have a high cost for the
equipment itself because my interest as
I started that Delta was to try and
create a protocol that can be deployed
in low and middle income countries in
areas to democratize access and so the
this particular platform at least are
the cost for hardware is the cheapest
platform of the next-gen sequencing
technologies I think that's a reasonably
verifiable statement and so that meant
that was probably in fact as cheaper
than a typical capillary sequencer of
the Sanger type so I think that that's
important and then the feasibility of
deploying this common protocol diverse
to your graphic settings i think this
established by our group we're writing a
manuscript and draft at the moment to
describe our experience with this but i
will tell you that it is feasible but it
still requires technical virtuosity to
be sure you're getting all of this right
and i think that the refinement to
further refinement of the informatics
pipeline and i think as you people learn
the protocol i think and there are good
measures of quality i think there's a
good opportunity to give what we need
out of this now the other thing i want
to highlight is that i'm interested in
moving beyond BR say of course but we
have to take it one step at a time this
is a paper that was originally by dr.
Stadler where this table was created
many have seen this table in different
settings in the upper left of the high
penetrance jeans the jeans are really
clinically relevant and have management
to go with them brca1 and brca2 the
colon cancer mismatch repair genes are
their hereditary gastric cancer from the
cdh1 gene leaf Romanian the p53 gene so
a lot of us would like to see multigene
panel approaches and I think these
platforms are adaptable to that sort of
approach in the middle is our biggest
challenge there are many modern machines
they aren't as much certain about how to
apply them but there nonetheless being
incorporated into panels in the bottom
right are the common but modest risk
variants which you can get from deep
sequencing in other ways of doing this
but I think that they're not as much
clinically useful at the moment
we're really focused on the upper left
we're adding the middle and soon I think
we'll be doing more overall but this is
a sort of a view to the future in the
current and the future actually as many
of the vendors in the US and elsewhere
have started to move to multigene panel
testing so current your breast ovarian
cancer affects all world populations
Sanger sequencing and screening for
large rearrangements is the gold
standard of beer City analysis I believe
that economic next-gen platforms could
be deployed to democratize access to
full PRC analyses and multigene genomic
panels I think the PRC analyses are
probably more critical at the moment and
that's because if you look at a pie
chart of hereditary breast cancer or
ovarian cancer seventy five to eighty
percent of the true positives are still
those two genes as compared to 10 or 15
genes to make up the next ten percent so
I think we made a lot of bang for the
buck if we go forward here I want to
acknowledge some of the funding for my
Latino work in particular the breast
cancer research foundation Avon
Foundation both critical support to our
work in Latin America previous NIHR 03
support and critical support from the
American Cancer Society both of my
genetic epidemiology and my behavioral
science work in Latinos so I believe
with that I have to put up this legal
last slide so to speak that this is for
research use only according to official
use and I think everybody understands
they have to get things to their own
relevant definitions of clinical grade
in their own setting following their own
local regulations but I think that's the
end of my presentation and will now open
it up to questions and answers and what
I'm going to do at this point is to
share this one thank you all for your
attention and I'm going to now turn over
alright so i guess i will have a less
Carol's able to unmute yourself I will
have to do the Q&A for you and so let me
go to some of the answer to the
questions so how long's are taking your
team to do this entire project and that
I will tell you that it's been we've
been working together for more than a
year we have presentation at American
side of human genetics from last fall
that is a poster that we're willing to
share happy to do so but we've been
working together for almost two years
but i think the preliminary work but by
mezan camp and Kosta i think was
critical to getting that going I think
it took them probably better part of six
to twelve months to get their initial
testing done any time you're trying to
coordinate a global consortium so seven
different centers each with a different
infrastructure all of us getting our
systems up and running you know that's a
challenge so we end up having to take
some time to get everybody up to speed
and then you get everybody coordinated
we're all doing the same protocol at the
same time so that it can be reproducible
so we can basically represent that this
should work for you too so I think
that's the idea but it's been a couple
of years and we're really looking to the
next level so you know we're really at
the point of okay let's really refine
this bottom for matix pathway make sure
it's doing what we wanted to do locally
now that we know that we can get the
sequence out of this machine and one of
the optimum parameters for spiking to
improve that one for the one applicant
had slightly less representation these
sort of things so so that's what we're
doing now I'm going to head back to
Carol for the moment cuz I think she
said she's got her great thank you so we
had another question around what was the
biggest need in terms of analysis
softwares what was really your needs for
this program for that
I think yeah there you go well I think
this good question but I'm going to tell
you that's really going to be more of a
question for the individual laughs many
labs have been doing different pathways
different workflows and there are a
number of workflows out there that i'm
sure you're anybody who's doing next-gen
sequencing knows there are multiple
different workflows I think the issue
here is that for our purposes i'm
looking for a system that can be turnkey
so my interest in seeing them get the
iron reporter to a point where it's
really easy to use and annotate it and a
custom way for brca1 and brca2
especially annotated for a given
population group so latinos I want to
get all the things that I already know
or variance because we've been testing a
lot of people so we know many of the
variance and if we can get them
annotated in workflow we don't have to
keep recognizing what appears to be the
u.s. is we already know their
polymorphisms and so part of it is
customizing the workflow and if you've
got a single need analyzing to specific
genes and you can customize the workflow
to represent that I think that works
fine that's my need because I want other
people who can do this to do it so I
want to build the hand this technology
of our should say the protocol off to my
collaborators in Latin America so they
can do their own testing in their own
sequencing however i would certainly
defer to others who have much more
experience in terms of the bottle lid
and lanolin pathways about the merits of
any given pathway so that's been my
biggest need is just having something
that's turnkey and can be customized and
i think probably it works for this way
you for that we have another question
that wants to know you mentioned that
there were 30 min aground in put DNA is
that the amount that was used for FFPE
samples or was that for a whole DNA and
is that the lowest you were able to go
for a sample input size I need your own
food pickup can is it okay we have
another question from a researcher who
wanted to understand about the input
amount that you use which is you
mentioned in the presentation 13
anagrams is that the lowest amount that
you were able to use and is that the
amount you used of FF alright so I'll
pick up so the next question I that I
saw was to what extent is the deep
sequencing information used for
personalized treatment that's an
interesting question I at this point
we're not talking about our consortium
was looking at germline germline
variants and brca2 know how to do if you
want to talk about personalized medicine
let me tell you that clinical cancer
genetics has been doing personalized
medicine for decades I'm identifying
hirez families doing Risk Reduction
surgeries doing enhanced surveillance so
we have data on MRI we have data on risk
reduction mastectomy we have data on all
cars all cause mortality reduction brew
for ectomy that is personalized
treatment we know what we need to do
once we identify the high risk now there
are others who of course use next-gen
sequencing to do deep sequencing of
tumors and identify targetable lesions
so I think that certainly it's possible
and this platform can do that the proton
I think because there's slightly shorter
read links is it I've been optimized to
some extent for formalin-fixed perform
better they'll take the next question
and sequencer because it's related to
the question before it which is you
mentioned 13 anagrams of DNA what about
which is for fresh formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded I didn't cite data
from ffpe
and I again i deferred to the techno
technological support staff regarding
that i know the group at the netherlands
doctor medicine camp and dr. i think of
it the moment i'm so my colleagues
they're all lichtenberg i know that they
published recently on the sequencing in
colon tumors of the mismatch repair
genes because they were able to use
formula ananza published paper so
perhaps we can post that afterward but
that's a published paper using the Ion
Torrent as a way of sequencing the
tumors for mismatch repair genes the
intent there was of course to establish
that it was an acquired somatic mutation
instead of a germline mutation
associated with the microsatellite
unstable colon tumor but they were able
to successfully amplify and analyze the
mismatch repair genes from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
I know that this method and this
circumstance is entirely possible to do
on formalin-fixed tissue this I believe
is excited because I'm we're actually
doing some pilot studies now to see if
we can detect germline mutations in
archival specimens and the reason is
that you don't always have the affected
person in the family to test if mom
developed breast cancer and died at a
young age if we have our tribal tissue
we may be able to use her as the bait
know as the check so that we know
whether our testing is informative so
other people talked about you know
there's some other technical questions
in this queue about how much for the
paraffin-embedded tissue analysis but
really not my forte here so I'm not
going to be able to address that
directly all right so let me just simply
have any other questions that were not
yet answered so I'm excited to try more
of these things but just trying to get I
think that might be the last of the
questions if i'm not mistaken yeah I
think that's it on the question so
anybody else please I we still have
about 80 people online so do look forth
any of the questions you might have
we're reaching the end of our hour
thank everybody I don't know Carol I'll
turn it over to you to see if you have
any other comments but I don't see any
other questions at the moment great
thank you dr. Weitzel I would love to
thank you for your wonderful
presentation and for all of you on the
line for participating we invite you to
join us for two additional presentations
that are coming over the next two days
on tomorrow we have a presentation from
Emma Bowden that's 7 30 to 8 30 it's
pacific standard time and that will
cover the bioinformatics session that
will speak about identification of
predictive biomarkers from
high-throughput drug combination
screening data and then on friday we
will cover a session again on oncology
that is about gene fusions that will be
at seven thirty in the morning until
eight thirty in the morning cific time
again if you would like to learn more
about ion torrent technologies and
products available through life
technologies please visit our booth this
can be accessed from the exhibit hall
through the home button on your screen
thank you very much and we've had some
questions about receiving the slides if
you would like to receive some of the
content that was presented here we do
have a poster in that booth that covers
the content that dr. whites will cover
today thank you very much